where would you guys hold up let's say
it happens right now and we have the
ability to go wherever we want to go
gotta be on an island right like a
remote island then you got to start
trying to find your own food and [__]
like that are you gonna fish though
right think if it came down to dying or
learning you would learn but there are
limitations obviously you're not going
to have medicine you're not gonna have
access to food outside of the fish but
you're not gonna have access to any of
that anyway well it depends depends
where you are and what you have to read
because eventually we're going to run
out of [__] we're gonna have to do rates
making your city around a source of
electricity that doesn't require gas
could be super valuable because you're
going to want some electricity
especially if you're going to try to
like Salvage Society I'm just gonna
become a zombie I kind of feel that no
one's happy everybody's like every day
you're nervous like that's no way to
live let me just be a cool zombie nugget
the book that I am Legend was based on
is kind of about that like is it worth
living if you're the only person really
left and everybody else seems dead like
what's the point of going is it worth it
and I kind of like at a certain point no